By Now We Should Be Very Comfortable Making
Bar Graphs to Represent Data We have
looked at normal bar graphs, joint bar
graphs, divided bar graphs and
percentage bar graphs but bar graphs are not the only way to present
the data. Look at this example
in which we can  C Different
Types of Cars and their Sales in a
Particular Month So in that month 150 Type A
cars were sold 100 Type B cars were 80 Type
C cars and 170 Type D cars were sold
First let us see how the bar graph for this
data would look like  Four years to represent the
sales of four types of cars
appropriately since we can see that car was the
best selling model in that month and lesser
numbers of cars seen and sold but there is no other way
in which we can represent this data coming
That's the only four types of
cars sold This is another way in that the data can be shown it's a
circle divided into
four parts or sectors of not necessarily the same
sizes if all the regions are sectors it means this
point has to be the  Center But What Are These
Reasons They Represent The Four Parts Sales
Of Each A B C And D Don't Worry About How We Do This We Will See That Soon Just Try To Understand
The Logic First Some This
Entire Circle Represents The Total
Number Of Car Sales  Ten four sum up to
500 500 cars and sold in this month represents
30 of the total sales which is
150 cars how we get this
30 150 di 500 in 100 and
30 in the same they b represents 20 out of
100 cars  C represents 16 f e 80 cars
and d represents 34 t is 170 cars
150 e 30 of
500 100 e % of 500 80
and 170 r 16 and 34
respectively the region A covers 30 of the
antays region B covers 20 of the antays and
region  C and D represent 16 and 34 of the
total We use the circle to represent the
total and make parts of it to represent each
category This
type of representation is called a pie
chart and what's the best example of a
pie chart Yes it's a pizza It's  A Pie
Chart with Equal Parts and Sectors
I Was Looking for Some Examples of Pie
Charts But Then I Thought I Should Make One
Myself So I Ask Many People a Question What Do You Do While
waiting for your
toast to pop up I drew a circle that
Represents The Number Of People I Approached Around
4 Per Of The People Told Me That They
Get Butter And Cutlery Out % Of The People Told
Me That They Clean Up The Kitchen And You Won't
Believe That's The Remaining 94 Told Me That They Just
Tear At  The toaster is that true
with us a few people were asked to category the
content of a pop song a circle was drawn
to represent the entire content around % was
actual lyrics 25 were the word
30 was the word oo and the remaining was  The
Word Pebe This Was Just a Funny Way to
Understand Pie Charts We'll Look at a
Couple of Serious Examples in Our Other
[Music]
Videos